- Hi, ladies.
I'm Tricia Hogan
from Pop News Daily
After Show Podcast.jpeg.
- Hi, there.
- Hi.
- You know you got movies,
television, kids,
how do you juggle it all?
- We just have a great squad
of people who help us out.
- Oh, yeah, a squad
of models and starlets.
- No, it's not like that.
- You wanna know what it's like?
- Then shut the [bleep] up
and listen.
[siren wailing]
both: [singing]
We've got a deep, dope squad
It takes a village, y'all
We got the best ladies
We've been told
that we roll deep, hey
The woman at the diner
Who always knows my order
- [singing]
My mammogram technician
- [singing] Dude who returned
my wallet intact
both: [singing]
Here's our gynecologist
Our real life gynecologist
We share a gynecologist
She's a huge part of our squad
- I think I get
what you guys are saying.
It's like...
[singing]
A queen ain't a queen
Just for sitting on a throne
She need a whole damn crew,
she can't do it alone
It's a healthy mix of friends
and assistants
Offering support
and taking care of business
Can't be M.I.A. from the P.T.A.
Cause you're picking up leche
from Trader Jose's
Slicin' to-do lists
like a samurai
All the while,
dealing with a U.T.I.
you guys are, like,
so, so down to earth.
- No, don't misunderstand,
bitch.
- Our squad is a veritable
who's who.
[singing]
We hanging with Gayle King
Robert Downey Sr.
You heard of Amy Schumer
- [singing] I did her show
so she owes me one
- [singing]
Favor.
- Wait, is this not
a charity thing?
- In a way.
- Sort of, yeah.
- You know what?
Let's just do a slow motion,
post-apocalyptic walk.
- Okay.
[laughter]
Wait, who are we mad at?
both: [singing]
We got a deep, dope squad
It takes a village, y'all
We got the best ladies
We've been told
that we roll deep, hey
[heavy bass electronic music]
- Oh, my God!
- Guys, you cannot just
trigger an explosion
and not tell people.
- It's a different world
now, guys.
- Tense times, tense times.
- Okay, everyone all right?
- No.
- You okay?
- No, I'm suing everyone here.
- Okay.